are you in better shape than you were in
your 20s if the answer is yes then you
just destroyed your beauty from your 20s
it doesn't mean you look like okay you
might technically they always get you on
like a technicality you might
technically look better but your natural
beauty was the best when you were
younger and and that's like the the um
there was like a video going around of
Tate and the funny thing is if you wig
the age Gap wider women will agree it's
just like when the age Gap is too small
so there's a video of him saying like
he'd prefer a 19 year old over a 26 year
old because they're like less damaged
and all this and I'm 26 and I'm like
yeah I mean even if even if you could
say you might be less damaged than the
average 26 year old you yourself were
less damaged five years ago